[Musique]
un certain nombre de journalistes
semblent s'est octroyé un pourboire de
juger un pouvoir même de condamner c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que moi
j'aime savoir d'où parle les gens
cherchent et j'ai su trouver des
réponses mais l étrave ainsi jamais
arrogé une qualité ou une compétence ou
une expertise sans que je n'avais pas je
pense que notre métier devrait un peu
douté de ses bases et les revoir et les
remettre en question a toujours eu un
rôle historique pour le meilleur et pour
le pire d'ailleurs parce que si on était
un petit allemands dans les années 30 on
l'a beaucoup entendu
hitler et ses potes à la radio puis
toutes les choses graves j'ai
l'impression qu'on les apprend par la
radio quand on écoute la radio on sait
si c'est grave ou si c'est pas grave
plus qu'à la télé
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver bonne année 2022 à tous nous
nous retrouvons comme chaque soir du
lundi au jeudi jusqu'à 21h30 pour des
clips t elle les grands titres de
l'actualité de la journée au sommaire de
ce lundi 10 janvier comment désamorcer
la crise ont tant de l'ukraine la
question est sur la table cette semaine
plusieurs rendez vous décisif entre les
occidentaux et la russie aujourd'hui des
pourparlers se sont tenues entre
washington et moscou en suis pas
d'accord trouvé mais les deux parties
tentent d'apaiser les tensions
retrouvera guillemard haussier en direct
de genève pour la russie demande
toujours que sa sécurité soit garantie
les américains disent ce soir être sans
réponse de moscou sur une demande de
désescalade alors peut-on s'attendre à
une sortie de crise dans les prochains
jours quel rôle peut avoir l'europe on
se penchera sur ces questions avec nos
invités
en france une visite emmanuel macron aux
allures de campagne présidentielle à
nice placée sous le signe de la sécurité
doubler les policiers sur le terrain
d'ici à 2030 c'est ce qu'a promis entre
autres le président de la république
lors de ce déplacement dans les alpes
maritimes la question sécuritaire qui
revient au centre des débats trois mois
jour pour jour de la présidentielle la
droite elle dénonce son bilan et évoque
un waterloo sécuritaire on en parlera
avec elle et six poulains
au sommaire à 21h le projet doit sur le
passeur vaccinale examiné au sénat
aujourd'hui avant son retour dans
l'hémicycle demain le gouvernement veut
que ce texte entre en vigueur dès lundi
prochain de quoi compliquer encore un
peu plus la vie des cinq millions de
français non vaccinées dans notre
rubrique qu'en pensent les français nous
irons justement à la rebond de l'un
d'entre eux qui dénonce une intrusion
dans son intimité alors le pass
vaccinale l'ultime fracture on attend
vos réactions sur le compte et des
grappes berthet france
[Musique]
la semaine de négociations est perçu
comme cruciale et décisive dans la crise
ukrainienne avec tout d'abord un
face-à-face russo américain qui s'est
achevée en fin de journée à genève des
pourparlers sans parvenir à un accord
mais qui prépare d'autres rencontres on
en parle tout de suite avec notre
envoyée spéciale à genève guillemin
aussi bon soit dieu m'a vous vous
trouvez donc devant la mission la
fédération de russie qu'est ce qui est
ressorti de ces négociations aujourd'hui
est bien un bon soir stéphanie est bien
en réalité pas grand chose à la formule
la plus appropriée ce soir ce serait
très certainement la fameuse expression
anglaise vous savez let's go 8 ou 10
bruit et convenions de nos désaccords en
bon français en réalité personne ne
s'attendait réellement avoir résolu ici
à genève en 24 heures seulement l'une
des plus graves crises diplomatiques
depuis la fin de la guerre froide même
sergueï ryabkov qui conduisait la
délégation russe n'afficher à la veille
de ces négociations qu'un optimisme le
plus prudent possible d'ailleurs je vous
propose de laisser le vice ministre des
affaires étrangères russe nous donner
ses impressions à l'issue de ces
pourparlers est écouté
cette discussion a été complexe longue
à un niveau très professionnelle
approfondie
concrètes
sans
tentative de
d'édulcorer telle ou telle chose
nous avons l'impression que la partie
américaine
considère les choses avec beaucoup de
sérieux notamment la proposition russe
et a effectué un travail de préparation
approfondie
si on comprend bien il y en a vraiment
et franchement avancées sur la crise
ukrainienne qu'est ce qui a bloqué
et bien à peu près tout stéphanie on va
commencer par rappeler les positions des
uns et des autres les américains
exigeait que la russie retire la
centaine de milliers d'hommes postés à
la frontière ukrainienne et qu'elle
cesse de qu'elle cesse ce que washington
considère comme une agression contre
kiev et moscou de son côté exigé que
l'otan stoppe son expansion vers l'est
c'est à dire en clair qu'elle refuse
l'entrée dans qu'elle refuse son
l'entrée à
kiev donc à l'ukraine comme nouveau
membre et qu'elle stoppe ses activités
militaires aux abords des frontières
russes et je vous propose d'écouter à
nouveau eu sergueï riabkov sur ces
sujets
donc nous allons favoriser
toute discussion tout
notamment sommet de l'otan pour formuler
ce que nous avions dit en 2008
c'est-à-dire sur les questions sur
l'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'otan
et il avait été dit déjà en 2008 que le
cren et la géorgie ne serait jamais
membres et je pense que si cela est
valide et encore une fois ce sera un
élément positif nous sommes las de voir
de ceux des mauvaises des demies
promesses des promesses non tenues
des
négociations à porte fermée nous voulons
nous voulons que tout soit validée
clairement souligner est que ces
garanties soient formulées juridiquement
et le fait aucune concession absolument
aucune concession en a été faite par
l'une ou l'autre des parties comme
d'ailleurs le laissaient présager les
déclarations officielles qui ont précédé
ces négociations c'est donc une journée
pour rien
alors peut-être pas tout à fait un
stéphanie d'abord parce que vous l'avez
dit il y à d'autres rendez vous à venir
celui de l'otan mercredi à bruxelles et
puis celui de l'eau et ce jeu de l'eau
et ce jeudi à vienne et les discussions
d'aujourd'hui seront certainement utile
à ces nouvelles négociations ensuite
parce qu états unis et russie ont évoqué
évoquer d'autres sujets comme
l'emplacement de missiles des manoeuvres
militaires en europe et même le futur
traité start-3 de réduction des armes
stratégiques nucléaires c'était en fait
d'ailleurs l'objectif initial de cette
rencontre et des précédents rendez-vous
du format ryabkov sherman ensuite parce
que refusé de faire la moindre
concession s'est aussi montré sa
détermination et sa fermeté ce qui est
toujours diplomatiquement très
intéressant pour chacun des deux camps
merci gaymard aussi notre envoyée
spéciale en direct de genève alors quel
enjeu donc un derrière cette crise
ukrainiennes moscou et washington
peuvent-ils éviter une confrontation
plus importante et l'europe dans tout ça
on prend de la hauteur avec nos invités
c'est l'heure de notre décryptage
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler sur ce
plateau régis le sommier grand reporter
rt france bonsant fois sur le registre
amis de vous retrouver bonne année à
vous d'ailleurs c'est plus depuis xavier
moreau à vous de vous retrouver aussi
directeur de strates pas de merci d'être
avec nous la situation qui n'est pas
désespérée mais que les états unis ne
devrait pas sous-estimer
c'est ce que nous dit on ce soir le
négociateur russe à l'issue de cette
journée à ne pas hausser sous-estimé le
risque d'une confrontation
le ton est plutôt à l'apaisement ont
finalement tout ça pour ça que javier
moro le cycle est à l'apaisement en fait
on a affaire à une réunion qui s'inscrit
dans un cycle qui on peut dire a démarré
dès l'année 2000 21 quand byden est
arrivé et que au grand dam d'une partie
justement des élites démocrate et même
républicaine il n'a pas été le vengeur
après les quatre années de trump avec
poutine et le moment clé je pense dès
2021 ça a été mi juin la rencontre à
genève où là visiblement il s'est passé
quelque chose la rencontre s'est
extrêmement bien passé ça d'ailleurs été
reproché à bayonne par sa presse et par
son électorat et par la suite on a vu
défiler à moscou
victorian hollande le chef de la cia
monsieur burns et de d'autres
rendez-vous ont eu lieu entre bayonne et
poutine par vidéoconférence est arrivé
il ya une semaine pour la première fois
la demande de la russie il faut bien
noter que c'est tout ce cycle est à la
demande des états unis à l'origine et là
on est dans une étape encore une fois
dans un cycle qui me paraît assez
positif et effectivement il ya
différents domaines sur lesquels ils
peuvent trouver des compromis y compris
le cren
vous partagez ce diagnostic de xavier
moreau l'arrêt plus tôt voilà à
l'optimisme et est à l'apaisement alors
ce qui est très intéressant c'est cette
ce dialogue justement je dirai au sommet
qui a lieu ça a été soulignée avec cette
première rencontre ne faut pas oublier
que pendant la crise sanitaire ça a été
la première fois que l'amiral vladimir
poutine se déplacer à l'étranger donc
c'était pour une occasion très
importante la première fois que joe
biden rencontré le président russe font
pas oublier qu'avant il y avait eu des
mots qu'elle a été quand même lâché il
avait traité de tueur
quand on lui avait dit vous allez
regarder dans ses yeux comme bush avait
dit je vais regarder son ami l'a dit non
j'ai regardé et je n'ai pas vu dame donc
quand même y avait quand même une
certaine tension entre les deux et puis
on se rend compte que finalement dans
ses rapports russo américain qui date
depuis 70 ans on a quand même amélioré
le fameux téléphone rouge vous savez
qu'on avait inventé en 1963 au moment
pour la désescalade kiki était un
téléphone voilà aujourd'hui on est dans
une visioconférence ça dure deux heures
ils se parlent ils se voient donc on est
quand même progressé et il est il faut
jamais négliger justement le le côté
premier plan des rapports humains alors
parfois ça a été exacerbée un des
présidents comme george bush ou comme
donald trump aimé jusqu'au moment où en
france des gens comme nicolas sarkozy
aimé avoir une relation personnelle
presque affective avec l'autre
dirigeants et je pense que ça pèse aussi
alors il faut voir moi je nuancerais
quand même une chose c'est que depuis
que les démocrates sont retournés au
pouvoir on a justement comme par hasard
une sorte d' accélération d'une nouvelle
guerre froide
alors je dis pas qu'elle est provoquée
par les américains les russes ont
certainement aussi leur part de
commandes dans dans cette histoire avec
ses troupes massées aux frontières mais
ses troupes massées aux frontières re
qu'est ce que c'est finalement depuis
2014 il ya environ 70 milles soldats
russes qui sont aux frontières de
l'ukraine c'est un il y a toujours ce
climat de guerre il y a toujours des
tranchées dans l'est et il ya des choses
qui ne sont pas réglés deux fois par an
environ le nombre de troupes russes
passent de 70000 à 100 milles pour des
manoeuvres qui ont lieu régulièrement
finalement quand on écoute les
ukrainiens d'ailleurs ils le disent le
disent très bien mais nous on n'a pas
peur des russes particulièrement n'a pas
peur d'une invasion parce que finalement
la guerre allait là et les troupes elles
sont toujours aux frontières avec la
différence cette fois-ci c'est là que ça
s'est accéléré depuis bei den est arrivé
au pouvoir c'est que l'armée ukrainienne
a été quand même largement équipés par
les américains dans les mois qui se sont
écoulés d'ailleurs le pentagone l'on
reconnaît notamment avec des missiles
javelin avec des drones bayrac tard donc
des drones türk qui sont ou ont été
particulièrement efficaces contre les
chars arméniens dans le conflit au
karabagh donc on sait que voilà il ya
des armes modernes qui sont arrivés et
russes ont dû adapter leur char pour
pouvoir les protéger contre ces menaces
donc là il ya effectivement une
tentative d' escalade mais la réalité
c'est que l'otan est présent et et qu'
un certain nombre de troupes y compris
de troupes françaises sont présentes
dans les balkans pour en cas de
justement d' escalade donc il ya
escalade d'un côté tension effectivement
les troupes massées mais également de
l'autre et ça c'est nouveau c'est arrivé
depuis je dirais que les démocrates sont
revenus au pouvoir et cette tentation
dans l'état profond américain de revenir
aux préceptes de brésil ce qui vous
savez du grand échiquier en 1997 qui qui
était l'homme qui voyait justement en
l'idée d'arracher l'ukraine à la russie
pour contrôler la zone et ça ça fait
partie des obsessions américaine et des
obsessions de guerre froide qui existent
encore aux états unis mais qui existe
aussi chez les russes on va aller voir
comment ça a été vécu du côté américain
cette journée on va faire un détour par
washington retrouver notre correspondant
thomas bonnet bonsoir thomas est
semble-t-il un washington reste plutôt
sur sa faim alors qu'il est et l'a fait
savoir d'ailleurs
oui il ya eu une conférence de presse
téléphonique de la part de wendy sherman
qui est donc la vice secrétaire d'état
américaine elle a expliqué d'abord sur
la forme qu'il s'agissait plutôt d'une
réunion où les deux parties on peut
exposer leur point de vue plutôt que de
réelles négociations et puis elle a fait
part de la position de fermeté de
washington quant aux demandes formulées
par moscou notamment sur une réduction d
activité militaire occidentale dans
l'est de l'europe il s'agit de
propositions vouée à l'échec selon la
vice secrétaire d'état américaine
écoutez la
nous n'autoriserons pas qui que ce soit
a fermé la politique portes ouvertes de
l'otan qui a toujours était centrale
dans l'alliance nous ne renoncerons pas
à la coopération bilatérale avec des
états souverains qui souhaite travailler
avec les états unis et nous ne prendrons
pas de décision sur l'ukraine sans
l'ukraine sur l'europe sans l'europe ou
sur l'otan sans l'otan
alors officiellement les états unis sont
toujours dans leur proposition de deux
voix possible d'avoir la voie
diplomatique favorisée par joe biden qui
pourrait donc mener à une désescalade
mais il ya aussi les menaces de
sanctions économiques sans précédent
c'est en tout cas comme ça qu'elles sont
présentées par les autorités américaines
en cas d' attaques de la russie contre
l'ukraine c'est une option qui est relié
très régulièrement dans les médias
américains qui sont volontairement
alarmiste il ya beaucoup d'articles dans
la presse américaine depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines pour alimenter cette
thèse d'une invasion imminente de
l'ukraine par les troupes russes ils
s'appuient souvent sur des sources
anonymes au sein des services de
renseignement et puis il ya aussi des
tribunes encore poster régulièrement et
récemment par les médias américains dans
lesquels des personnalités américaines
appellent joe biden à faire part de la
plus grande fermeté possible face à
vladimir poutine merci thomas bonnet
xavier moreau vous nous parliez
justement c'est pas facile pour joe
biden cette position c'est un peu de
l'équilibrisme il faut apaiser les
choses avec moscou et répondre à une
opinion publique qui demande beaucoup de
fermeté exactement je pense qu'il faut
prendre de la distance avec les
déclarations de notamment a eu le ce
ministre américain des affaires
étrangères c'est quand même elle qui est
venue chercher directement à moscou le
document qui était remis officiellement
des des requêtes russe sur cette
question ensuite votre correspondant
lundi de manière tout à fait juste il
faut pas écouter ni leur les médias
américains les médias américains sont là
pour faire croire un électorat démocrate
que joe biden est dur avec poutine ce
qu'on observe c'est pas du tout ça
aujourd'hui en faites quoi qu'il arrive
le grand vainqueur de cette au moins sur
un point une première étape de ces
grandes négociations c'est vladimir
poutine parce que aujourd'hui on est
revenues à un niveau où en fait on
abandonne en direct avec poutine il
manque plus que si jean ping et ont fait
un nouveau yalta pour ce pour se
partager les ondes influence donc pour
la russie c'est tout bénéfice et il faut
pas y vous l'avez dit également en
présentation de votre de votre programme
il faut personnes attendaient une un
débouché radical après cette réunion
c'est une réunion qui s'inscrit dans un
cycle il y en aura une prochaine et en
attendant la situation et je les en
ukraine évidemment que les russes ne
vont pas en verrine aucun intérêt de le
faire et les quais vient surtout non pas
le bleu n'ont pas l'autorisation de
washington de lancer ce dont il rêve
c'est-à-dire une opération nettoyage
ethnique dans le donbass est régis le
sommier c'est vrai que les les les
premières réactions elles ne seront pas
à la russie n'a pas apporté de réponse à
la demande américaine de désescalade à
la frontière ukrainienne mais moscou
elle se montre satisfaite du sérieux
avec lequel et les américains avaient
accueilli les demandes russe ça ce sont
les réactions des deux pays ça veut dire
que le rapport de force il est plutôt en
faveur de moscou aujourd'hui moscou 10
en gros impression que moscou est plus
satisfaite que washington s'est un peu
lol le bleu alors la question sur sur le
fond et sur l'empreinte que voudra
laisser joe biden dans la diplomatie
américaine et et surtout surtout sur sur
l'échiquier international
risque quand même d'être contrarié vous
vous mentionniez tout de suite là là
comment là
virulence de la presse américaine à
l'encontre de la russie est un vieux
classique de la halle la peur kid athlé
d'époque de ce qu'on appelait la red
scraire la peur rouge et qu'on est con
alimentons c'est un chiffon qu'on
enfonce coup assez régulièrement byden
et ne peut pas non plus complètement
laissé tomber cet aspect là parce que
vous savez qu'il ya bientôt les
élections de mi-mandat que la popularité
de baden est quand même très mise en
cause enfin il ya un an il a un vrai
problème de popularité aux états unis et
qui risque fortement de perdre ces
élections de mi mandat et comme tout
président américain quand tu arrives
cette perspective dès mi mandat quand il
n'a pas réussi à plat à passer son plan
il ya eu eux comment il n'y a pas eu
vraiment de grosses de grande avancée ni
il n'a réussi à faire oublier les
retraites alors qu'ils s'étaient promis
de le faire donc joe biden est un peu
coincé entre une opinion américaine qui
sera volontairement comment réceptif
justement à cet égard au fait qu'on
brandisse une menace russe quelque part
et que l'amérique redevienne un peu ce
ce flambeau de la démocratie
internationale c'est un peu ce que ce
que et donc pour pouvoir justement
trouver une manière de dire 'voilà
george aurait affirme la plainte la
puissance américaine
byden peut être tentée et un certain
nombre de ses ministres également
d'appuyer sur ce bouton en sachant aussi
également qu'un élément qu'on oublie
fréquemment c'est la posture américaine
pendant le retrait d'afghanistan qui a
été vécu par beaucoup d'américains comme
une humiliation et qui est une tâche
pour manque pour le moment sur le
parcours de joe biden tâche qui
évidemment dont s'est emparé donald
trump et un certain nombre d'opposants
aux républicains en disant que ce
retrait américain avait été
l'humiliation est donc là bas y donne
est nécessairement obligé quelque part
de reprendre le flambeau et de dire non
nous sommes nous sommes là et l'amérique
est de retour oui je pense que il ya un
point positif pour joe biden c'est que
contrairement à trump il peut manoeuvrer
avec le congrès parce que trump dès
qu'il faisait quelque chose en direction
de la russie on l'accusé d'être un agent
du kremlin est aujourd'hui bailon
contrôle beaucoup mieux sa majorité
démocrate que
trump contrôler sa majorité républicaine
puisque je virais la russophobie au
congrès américain est les trans courants
et aujourd'hui on l'a vu d'ailleurs les
un groupe de sénateurs mené par eux
mêmes toujours tête rousse qui est un
républicain a essayé de de faire voter
dans le budget de la défense américaine
l'automatisation des sanctions c'est à
dire que en gros l'exécutif c'est à dire
joe biden aurait perdu la main sur le
moment où mettre les sanctions ce qui
pouvait vraiment déclenché tout
simplement la cession des relations
diplomatiques comme l'a dit vladimir
poutine avec la russie et joe biden a
obtenu des démocrates qu'ils ne votent
pas 7 7 7
requête de donc du congrès donc
aujourd'hui malgré tout malgré
l'hostilité donc on estimait être de joe
biden contre la contre la russie
aujourd'hui il a il a les moyens il a
les clés et d'obtenir un succès
de prestige voire plus non seulement sur
le cren mais selon l'iran mais sur
d'autres dossiers où la russie est moins
et moins à cheval on va dire sur les
principes alors concernant justement le
regard entre les occidentaux porte sur
cette question reste on propose
d'écouter un point de vue assez
intéressant et plutôt dissonances matin
c'était dans les colonnes du figaro
celui de georges bible vice président du
center for the national interest
l'ancien directeur d' analyse de la
russie à la cia écouté
beaucoup d'analystes qu'on parle la
russie avec l'ancienne urss selon cette
grille de lecture particulièrement vogue
aux etats unis les actions de vladimir
poutine serait motivé par une volonté de
confrontation avec les pays
démocratiques je pense que c'est une
erreur d'analysé fondamentale la russie
a plutôt une obsession assez
traditionnel pour sa sécurité cette
obsession se traduite de plusieurs
façons l'une d'entre elles est de tout
faire pour ne pas être menacé par ses
voisins au cours de son histoire la
russie a été envahie à de nombreuses
reprises ce qui la rend extrêmement
sensibles à ce risque régis se soigner
c'est vrai que c'est une opinion qu'on
entend peu en occident mais en gros
voilà on n'a pas la bonne lecture des
motivations russe d'ailleurs il le dit
un pays dit on se focalise sur les
lecteurs idéologique qui nous empêche de
voir les motivations russe en clair les
russes ont envoyé des signaux qui sont
restés incompris
oui je crois que en effet il y a dans ce
ces propos une sagesse assez remarquable
notamment de la part d'un américain et
d'un ex représentant représentants de la
cia qui est de devoir la russie
aujourd'hui comme un pays qui a toujours
ses tentations et qui a toujours la
réussite était une nation mais une
nation qui n'a pas de frontière à et
kiki acquis à un ensemble considérable
et qui ne peut pas qui ne raisonnent pas
de la même façon que les français par
rapport aux allemands par rapport mais
qui dans l'histoire sa a été noté
pendant dans cette déclaration a été
attaqués plusieurs fois a été en presque
envahi et qu'à chaque fois il ya une
capacité la russie a su trouver une
capacité de résistance incroyable il ya
un autre élément qui me paraît important
dans la comparaison justement entre ou
deux roues le fait de dire il ne faut
plus comparé la rousse la russie dirigée
par vladimir poutine aujourd'hui avec
l'urss c'est que dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui la russie n'a pas
d'ambition idéologique elle n'est pas là
pour propager une idéologie communiste
qui serait le bonheur de l'humanité et
et dont il faudrait que tous les pays
s'imprègne on n'est plus dans cette
époque là il n'ya plus celle ce prisme
idéologique
ils y achètent la russie dans la rue si
l'idée d'être une puissance
internationale une puissance qui compte
avec des tentations un père les
impérialistes c'est clair mais mais qui
est une puissance qui a voulu et qui je
pense notamment à travers la pièce la
crise syrienne a regagné et le
désengagement américain faut pas
l'oublier on est d'un côté avec une
russie qui veut retrouver une place et
d'un autre côté en train et man
les etats-unis qui ne veulent plus être
les gendarmes du monde et qu'ils ont
montré à plusieurs reprises parlé de
tout à l'heure du retrait d'afghanistan
mais ça a été le cas aussi en irak a
essayé c'est le cas c'est à dire les
états unis ne veulent plus s'engager
dans des guerres qui leur coûtent des
fortunes et qui finalement ne mène à
rien et qui n'arrive pas à terminer et
ils ont une posture n'oublions jamais
que et barack obama et donald trump si
on ne peut bien leur trouver un point
commun c'est que c'est des présidents
qui ont été élus sur des mandats anti
guerre contre les guerres de george bush
et donc d'un côté on a ça donc on a une
amérique qui recule et une russie qui
elle veut retrouver une part de son
prestige animaux oui oui je pense que ça
appelle deux remarques tout d'abord il
ya une prise de conscience aujourd'hui
chez les élites américaines y compris
démocrates de ce qu'est réellement la
russie est un article qui était publié
dans free fr il ya une semaine et font
rien à faire c'est la voix du ministère
des affaires étrangères américain dans
lequel deux chercheurs expliquent que
poutine n'a pas reproduit les erreurs
économiques de l'urss et que donc il ne
sert à rien de sanctionner la russie que
ça ne fera que renforcer y compris les
non seulement la puissance de l'impact
devenir poutine sur son propre pays mais
l'économie russe donc il ya il ya eu il
ya un courant réaliste qui est en train
de prendre le dessus aux etats unis que
ce soit chez les républicains que ce
soit les démocrates ensuite par rapport
à l'ajustement la tentation impériale
russe il faut se rappeler que vladimir
poutine fait partie de cette élite ruche
qui considère que l'urss est d'ailleurs
l'empiré russe est allé trop loin ça
c'est très bien expliqué dans les
mémoires de yevgeny primakov qui est
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup inspiré
vladimir poutine c'est à dire que ce qui
compte aujourd'hui pour vladimir poutine
c'est les frontières russes et les
russes à l'étranger donc par exemple
l'idée que la russie envahisseuses betis
temps le kazakhstan ou les pays baltes
ça ne se pose même pas lier poutine ne
veux pas que la france que pardon que la
russie s'épuise que s'épuise dans des
anciens territoires qui ne lui serviront
de toute manière à rien si la russie a
construit trois ports dans la baltique
c'est bien parce qu'elle ne veut pas
revenir dans les pays baltes voyez donc
et je pense que ça maintenant une partie
des élites américaines à une approche
réaliste c'est pour ça encore une fois
je suis plutôt optimiste justement vous
m'offrez la transition parce qu'on va
évidemment parler du kazakhstan tout à
l'heure régis avait aussi l'un des
dossiers les etats-unis apprécient pas
vraiment l'attitude russe sur sur le
dossier du kazakhstan encore un point de
discorde un point de discorde oui et
c'est évident puisqu'il ya voit la
révolte au kazakhstan donc on va
forcément agitée toujours le chiffon des
peuples quitte à trouver une révolution
avec un une couleur et et l'a baptisé et
tout à coup montrer finalement que la
russie réprime alors que finalement
elles obéissent elle obéit finalement un
accord qu'elle a conclu avec le
kazakhstan bien qu'un certain nombre de
partenaires sur la région de
rétablissement de l'ordre donc oui la
question kazakh ne peut pas être d'abord
qu'au comparé à la question ukrainienne
je pense que ça c'est c'est une histoire
de politique interne une histoire en
effet d'augmentation des prix des
carburants et une histoire de révolte
populaire aussi mais il y avait aussi un
commandant là dans la sphère quête du
kazakhstan des tentatives de
déstabilisation à l'intérieur même de la
deûle de l'appareil politique kazakh
merci à tous des deux rives et se sont
mis et xavier moreau d'avoir été avec
nous et justement à le président du
kazakhstan qui assure lui que son pays a
vaincu aujourd'hui à une tentative de
coup d'état il fait référence aux
émeutes meurtrières de la semaine
dernière il promet également le départ
son pain des troupes russes appelé à la
rescousse elle la vie reprend en tout
cas son cours normal almaty les
habitants constatent les dégâts tout en
se disant soulagé par l'arrivée des
troupes de maintien de la paix les
précisions sur place de mourad des f a
envoyé spécial d'ayrté international
il serait injuste de dire que des
manifestations pacifiques au kazakhstan
ont uniquement causé des dommages
économiques il ne s'agit pas de
manifestations pacifiques mais des
meutes de chaos et de pillages
en quelques jours elles ont entraîné
plus de 200 millions de dollars de
dégâts pour le pays principalement ici
dans la ville d'almaty et il s'agit
d'estimations préliminaires car les
dommages réels devraient être beaucoup
plus important
à plusieurs reprises les autorités
kazakhes ont indiqué que ce mouvement
n'était pas spontanée qu'il s'agissait
de pillage organisé avec des mouvements
de foule visant systématiquement les
centres commerciaux et des entreprises
dans ce centre commercial les caméras de
vidéosurveillance ont enregistré des
incidents ici comme ailleurs les
pillards ont commencé par le plus facile
les magasins électroniques les
bijouteries ainsi que les distributeurs
automatiques de billets ceci par exemple
était en magasin de téléphonie il ne
reste que quelques appareils kc
les étagères ont été dévalisés en
quelques minutes les gardiens n'ont rien
pu faire alors que la police répliquer
aux tirs des gangs armés pendant ce
temps les pillards ont fait main basse
sur la ville
sans aucun doute tout ceci était
planifiée car les gens qui sont venus et
ont agi ci possédait l'équipement
adéquat il faut avoir le matériel
nécessaire pour forcer des distributeurs
automatiques elie sont parvenus ils se
sont emparés des liasses de billets
bien sûr que ça fait peur nos citoyens
étaient chez eux après la fête du nouvel
an tout le monde se reposer nous ne
savions pas du tout ce que c'était
lorsque nous nous sommes réveillés
il y avait des citoyens étrangers là il
y avait une sorte d'agitation là-bas des
voix est en réalité ce bruit a été
probablement causée par des portes qu'on
défonce est que peut dire un retraité je
reste chez moi et j'ai peur de sortir
c'est tout c'est très bien que nous
ayons des soldats de la paix maintenant
ces moments ont été terrifiant pour les
civils beaucoup se sont cachés chez eux
lumières éteintes pour éviter d'attirer
l'attention tandis que les gangs ravagé
la ville d'almaty il ne pouvait rien
faire il n'y avait personne à appeler
pour avoir de l'aide jusqu'à l'arrivée
des soldats de maintien de la paix à
l'aéroport désormais sécurisé d'almaty
des évacuations sont en cours des russes
et des ressortissants d'autres pays sont
évacués vers l'étranger à bord de vols
charters et d'avions cargos militaires
ceux qui l'ont vécue ne peut être décrit
autrement que comme une épreuve
maintenant la situation est revenue plus
ou moins à la normale dieu merci nous
attendions ses vols pour être évacués
nous avons rencontré cette foule qui
était déjà armé nous logions dans un
hôtel qui donnait sur la place nous
avons vu tout cela brûle et
une centaine de passagers vont être
évacués rien qu'avec ce vol militaire
au total près d'un millier de personnes
ont contacté le consulat russe et ont
demandé à être évacués de la ville
d'almaty
ils embarqueront à bord d'une dizaine de
vols différents
les autorités nous ont indiqué qu'elle
s'attendait à ce que davantage de
personnes contacter le consulat et
demande une évacuation notamment les
ressortissants étrangers
un anniversaire sous haute tension en
bosnie herzégovine la république serbe
de bosnie a fêté ses 30 ans dans un
climat d'instabilité hier cette province
est engagé depuis plusieurs mois dans un
bras de fer avec les institutions
centrales des pays sont leaders
politiques menacent de faire sécession
les explications avec à thibaut jana
okla mais il y a trente ans la
république serbe de bosnie herzégovine
est l'une des trois provinces d'un pays
divisé le caractère sécessionniste de sa
création est l'une des origines des
guerres en ex-yougoslavie signé à paris
par le croate franjo tudjman le serbe
slobodan milosevic et le bosnien alija
izetbegovic
les accords de dayton met fin à la
guerre interethnique et assure à la
république serbe de bosnie une
reconnaissance territoriale et politique
plus d'une décennie plus tard certaines
tensions persistent et le mouvement
nationaliste serbe gagne du terrain un
sondage de l'institut partenaires révèle
que plus des trois quarts des serbes de
bosnie serait favorable à une sécession
si les albanais du kosovo se déclaraient
indépendant de la serbie après avoir
occupé la présidence du gouvernement
milorad dodik est élu président de la
république serbe de bosnie dès le
premier tour il a été reconduit pour un
second mandat de quatre ans en 2014 24
ans après la création de l'entité serbe
la célébration de cet anniversaire est
considérée comme illégale par les
autorités fédérales pour les croates et
les bosniaques
cette célébration constitue une
provocation en vue d'une future
réunification avec la serbie
en 2018 milorad dodik et élus
représentants serbes à la présidence
collégiale de bosnie herzégovine
il occupe le poste de président durant
les huit premiers mois du mandat puis de
novembre 2020 à juillet 2021 après l
annonce d'un boycott des institutions
centrales l'assemblée de la république
serbe adopte une loi actant le retrait
de l'entité du système judiciaire
national de l'administration fiscale ou
encore de l'armée bosnienne inscrit
depuis 2010 est sur la liste noire du
trésor américain milorad dodik est de
nouveau visé par les états unis
l'administration byden l'actus de
menacer la stabilité des balkans et
impose des sanctions financières
votre présence ici est une réponse à
tous ceux qui nient notre existence qui
disent que nous ne pouvons pas à
célébrer ce jour nous leur montrons que
nous pouvons et ceux qui nous imposent
constamment des sanctions c'est notre
preuve que je suis ici choisi par les
gens je ne suis pas là pour faire ce que
les américains veulent que je fasse mais
je suis ici pour faire ce que veulent
les gens
ces sanctions n'ont pour le moment eu
aucun impact sur la politique de milorad
dodik la stabilité de l'état fédéral de
bosnie herzégovine reste fragile à
sarajevo certains observateurs voient
2022 comme une année charnière pour
l'avenir du pays
et dans le reste de l'actualité le début
aujourd'hui des pourparlers au soudan
des discussions entre civils et
militaires sous l'égide de l'onu
khartoum est plongée dans une crise
politique depuis le putsch du 25 octobre
dernier un coup d'état qui a déclenché
une vague de protestations dans le pays
les manifestations émaillées de violence
63 soudanais ont été tués dans la
répression françois xavier lambert
[Applaudissements]
nouveau pouvoir militaire scandé ces
manifestants ce dimanche la rue
soudanaise a de nouveau hurlait sa
colère contre les militaires malgré un
important dispositif de sécurité des
milliers de personnes ont tenté de se
rassembler devant le palais présidentiel
de khartoum
pour les disperser les forces de l'ordre
ont multiplié les tirs de gaz
lacrymogène nous voulons annulé le coup
d'état qui a eu lieu au soudan et
appuyer la transition démocratique nous
rejetons le gouvernement militaire et le
gouvernement du général abdelfattah al
bourhane je suis sorti aujourd'hui pour
protester contre le gouvernement
militaire nous voulons un gouvernement
civil en plus de la liberté de la paix
de la sécurité et de la justice sous un
gouvernement démocratique malgré ces
manifestations massives l'armée détient
désormais seul le pouvoir la semaine
dernière le premier ministre civil
censée mener la transition a démissionné
il avait pourtant été réinstallés dans
ses fonctions en novembre après avoir
été renversée une première fois lors du
coup d'état militaire du 25 octobre à la
tête de l'armée le général al burhan
concentre l'essentiel des critiques ce
dernier assure pourtant prendre la
mesure de la situation vous êtes tous
conscient de la situation difficile que
traverse notre pays et de l'ampleur des
défis et des crises qui menacent
l'entité de la patrie ce sont en fait
des menaces existentielles qui ne
peuvent être ignorées et qui ne peuvent
être affrontés qu'avec une pleine
conscience d action pure un sentiment
d'appartenance à la patrick et en
plaçant son intérêt au dessus de tout
autre intérêt
malgré ces paroles la défiance à son
égard s'est renforcée après sa décision
de prolonger de deux ans son mandat à la
tête du pays le leader de la junte a
promis des élections pour juillet 2023
mais ces opposants réclament la mise en
place d'un gouvernement civil
immédiatement pour trouver une issue à
cette crise les nations unies ont
annoncé des pourparlers avec tous les
acteurs civils et militaires à partir de
ce lundi
des négociations ont d'ores et déjà
rejeté par une partie des manifestants
est sur le continent africain toujours
les relations s'enveniment entre le mali
la cedeao les dirigeants ouest africains
prennent une série de mesures contre
bamako pour une restitution de pouvoir
aux civils en réponse le mali ferme ses
frontières au buzzer de la cedeao et
rappelle ses ambassadeurs nicolas
fontaine
nouveau coup dur pour le peuple malien
réunis au ghana les dirigeants des pays
de la cedeao ont décidé de frapper fort
face à la junte au pouvoir et à son
projet de diriger le mali pendant cinq
années supplémentaires un calendrier de
transition qui ne passe pas initialement
prévu le 27 février prochain les
élections présidentielle et législatives
n'auront finalement pas lieu pour la
junte ces élections ne peuvent se tenir
en raison de l'aggravation de
l'insécurité dans le pays mais pour les
dirigeants des pays de l'afrique de
l'ouest ce revers est une atteinte au
processus démocratique
or
l'autorité déplore profondément le
manque évident est flagrant de volonté
politique des autorités de transition
qui a conduit à l'absence de tout
progrès dans la préparation de
l'élection malgré la volonté de la
cedeao et de tous les partenaires
régionaux et internationaux pour
accompagner le mali dans ce processus
lors de leur rencontre les membres de la
cedeao ont conclu des sanctions
historique envers le mali sanctions
politiques mais également économique
ces sanctions supplémentaires
comprennent le retrait des ambassadeurs
de tous les états membres de la cedeao
au mali deuxièmement la fermeture des
frontières terrestres et aériennes entre
les pays membres de la cedeao et le mali
troisièmement la suspension de toutes
les transactions commerciales et
financières entre les états membres de
la cedeao et le mali
la junte a réagi à ces sanctions et a
également rappelé ses ambassadeurs
présents dans les pays de la cedeao le
gouvernement du monique condamne
énergiquement
ces sanctions illégales et illégitimes
prises à la fois pas lieu mois et la
cedeao
organisation pourtant fondée sur la
solidarité
l'idéal panafricain
le gouvernement du mali regrette que des
organisations sous régionale ouest
africaine se fasse instrumentalisés par
des puissances extra régionale aux
desseins inavoués en réaction à cette
marche arrière
de nombreux maliens se sont rendus
samedi devant le monument des martyrs de
bamako pour manifester et dire stop au
pouvoir en place nous pensons
aujourd'hui que il faut le plus que
possible par les sortir pour dire si une
transition ce n'est pas possible et nous
avons estimé qu' il n'y avait pas de
lieu plus propice pour rappeler à la
mémoire de tous les maliens l'importance
de la démocratie que le monument des
martyrs devant lesquels nous trouvons
aujourd'hui il n'est pas concevable
qu'un régime d'exception s'éternise
c'est à nos autorités de faire preuve de
responsabilité pour ne pas tirer trop
fort sur la courbe et a entraîné une
rupture dans le dialogue avec la
communauté économique des états de
l'afrique
bargot économique qui risque d'aggraver
le quotidien d'une population malienne
déjà douloureusement impacté par la
pandémie de kobe de 19
le mali qui peine à se relever depuis
ces deux coups d'état en 2020 et 2021 et
qui cristallise aujourd'hui toute la
crise sécuritaire du sel menacé depuis
2012 par les insurrections jadistes
très direction présents le cameroun où
se déroule la coupe d'afrique des
nations de football en ce moment une
canne qui prendra fin le 6 février une
compétition bien particulière crise
sanitaire oblige mais pas que quand un
mot clair
non
jour de fête dans la capitale
camerounaise après un report d'un an en
raison de la situation sanitaire la 33e
coupe d'afrique des nations a enfin
donné son coup d'envoi ce mercredi une
compétition attendue par les fans du
ballon rond mais qui se déroule dans un
contexte sanitaire compliqué pandémie de
covin 19 oblige des mesures ont été
mises en place pour accéder au stade
enregistrement en ligne vaccination ou
encore tests négatifs
l'ensemble de ces facteurs sont
notamment demandés pour voir un match
pour autant toutes ces restrictions ne
semblait pas avoir d'effet sur la
motivation des supporters camerounais
[Musique]
il est vrai que j'ai écrit
alibert c'était contre la vaccination
j'ai été vraiment
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment été motivé cette fois ci
dans le passé en bandits dans le monde
entier qui al hader et pas mauvais mais
quand vous voyez là et vous voyez
l'image de la der je ne pense pas là on
est il ya tout le monde on a les arbres
phone on a tout le monde tout le monde
aimerait beaucoup aidé aujourd'hui c'est
pour ça cet amour preuve que le coc vite
19 risque de perturber le bon
déroulement de la compétition
plusieurs joueurs de différentes
sélections ont déjà été testés positifs
ces derniers jours en plus de la
situation sanitaire s'ajoute un contexte
sécuritaire compliqué au cameroun au
nord ouest et au sud ouest du pays dans
les régions habitées par la minorité
anglophone des affrontements sanglants
ont lieu entre groupes armés et forces
de sécurité selon l'onu et des ong lors
des quatre dernières années ces
violences auraient fait plus de 3500
morts principalement des civils
le président paul biya a tenté de
rassurer sa population lors de ses voeux
pour 2022 je voudrais à nouveau redire
la détermination inébranlable du
gouvernement à restaurer la paix dans
les régions en proie à des menaces
sécuritaires aux violences
intercommunautaires viennent s'ajouter
la menace djihadiste au nord du pays le
groupe terroriste boko haram a déjà
commis de nombreuses attaques depuis
2015 la dernière exaction a eu lieu dans
la nuit du 16 au 17 décembre dernier six
civils d'un village proche de la
frontière nigériane avait alors été
tuées et autres sujets de préoccupation
dans la région la sécurité dans le pays
voisin du cameroun au nigeria la semaine
dernière au moins 200 personnes ont été
tuées par des groupes armés dans le
nord-ouest du pays depuis plusieurs
années cette partie phoebé cette partie
fait face à une vague d'attaqués qui
provoque le déplacement de milliers de
personnes les explications en images
d'yves olivier
le nord ouest du nigeria a une nouvelle
fois été la proie d'extrême violence
faisant plusieurs centaines de morts des
hommes armés ont lancé des attaques dans
les villages de l'état de zamfara selon
un responsable gouvernemental
pour certains experts en sécurité elles
sont une réponse aux opérations de
l'armée nigériane visant à les déloger
de la zone environ dix mille civils
seraient actuellement sans logement
alors que leurs maisons ont été rasées
par les assaillants selon le communiqué
de la ministre des affaires humanitaires
à la télévision nigériane le président
mohamadou buhari a réaffirmé sa volonté
de lutter contre ce qu'il a qualifié de
terroriste
une formule utilisée afin de pouvoir
durcir les sanctions à l'encontre des
auteurs de ces actes et qu'ils viennent
en appui des chiffres de l'armée les
militaires nigériens revendique
l'élimination de 537 bandits armés et
autres éléments criminels ainsi que
l'arrestation de 374 personnes depuis
mai 2000 20 mais ces statistiques
prennent sans doute en compte un combat
d'un autre genre celui contre les
terroristes de boko haram le confier
avec ces groupes djihadistes a engendré
près de 350 mille victimes et forfaits
plus de deux millions de personnes à
quitter leur foyer selon un rapport de
l'onu datant de fin 2020 autre menace
pour le pays les enlèvements d'élèves
dans les écoles collèges et lycées de
plus en plus nombreux depuis décembre
2020 plus de mille étudiants ont été
enlevés la plupart reviennent après
versement d'une rançon
la politique en france à trois mois jour
pour jour du premier tour de la
présidentielle emmanuel macron défend le
bilan sécuritaire de son quinquennat et
dévoile ses projets en cas de réélection
en visite à nice pour l'inauguration
d'un hôtel des polices le président fait
plusieurs annonces aujourd'hui il a
notamment promis une hausse de 1,15
milliard d'euros sur cinq ans du budget
sécuritaire emilie gogh h
la sécurité thème désormais
incontournable dans la campagne
présidentielle
emmanuel macron n'a pas encore
officialisé sa candidature qu'il passe
déjà à l'offensive devant des élus des
associations ou encore des membres des
forces de l'ordre il promet une hausse
du budget de la sécurité de l'ordre de
15 milliards d'euros sur cinq ans
emmanuel macron qui souhaite doubler le
nombre de policiers sur le terrain c'est
d'ici 2030 on met de l'argent on
investit on forme plus mais on organise
mieux aussi c'est ce qu'on doit à nos
compatriotes pour avoir plus de monde
présent sur le terrain et efficace et on
a un objectif qui est de doubler la
présence policière sur la voie publique
à l'horizon 2030 le président a
également fait d'autres annonces
toujours sur le plan sécuritaire comme
la création de 200 brigade de
gendarmerie en milieu rural d'une force
d'action républicaine pour les quartiers
de 1500 cyberpatrouilleurs
supplémentaires ou encore le triplement
des amendes en cas de harcèlement de rue
emmanuel macron a également tenu à
défendre le bilan sécuritaire de son
quinquennat
est donc là on a donc créé ces 10000
postes supplémentaires qui sont en train
de se déployer on a créé des
partenariats opérationnels 923 on a ces
fameux 62 quartier de reconquête
républicaine que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure et on a augmenté d'un peu plus
de 10% la présence policière sur le
terrain un bilan sur lequel le président
reste toutefois très attaqués par la
droite eric ciotti député des
alpes-maritimes et soutien de valérie
pécresse candidate les républicains à la
présidentielle l'accusent de laisser aux
français une société ensauvagé et une
france orange mécanique
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
alexis poulain éditorialistes bonsoir
alexis ravi de vous retrouver vous allez
braves ye brave à paris voilà vous voilà
enfin ce plateau à ma grande joie nos
quatre mois depuis l'inde la
présidentielle cette visite dans le sud
de la france sur le thème de la sécurité
quel est le but et a affiché évidemment
qu'il a un petit peu de buts cachés
comme urbain le but affiché c'est quand
même incroyable ce président qui n'est
pas candidat mais qui est un candidat
perpétuel là il fait des promesses de 15
milliards sur cinq ans comme s'il était
déjà réélu comme s'il n'y avait pas
d'élections et pourtant
d'où vient ce plan il ya bien sûr eu le
beauvau de la sécurité il est sur les
terres dans le sud à nice accueilli par
christian estrosi ancien et l'eire qui
est maintenant chez horizon clairement
pour draguer cet électorat là pour aller
chasser là où les républicains sont
forts sur les thèmes aussi qu'ils sont
les thèmes de prédilection des
républicains le régalien la sécurité et
on voit bien que il passe son temps en
fait à chercher où sont les voies et à
empêcher ses opposants finalement
d'exister en préemptant leur sujet avec
la force de frappe d'un président de la
république les moyens de la présidence
de la république donc le jeu est
totalement inégal et ce candidat qui
n'est pas déclarée et évidemment
officiellement candidat même s'il ne dit
pas que c'est officiel quand on voit ces
déclarations aujourd'hui en adresse de
la police et sur la sécurité est
évidemment lexine moyen pour lui de
chasser sur les terres
traditionnellement à droite un à l'air
évidemment les thèmes clés et se
positionner en force dans le match
pécresse macron oui bien sûr puisque
valérie pécresse
l'ancien campagne et a bien du mal à
exister en train eric zemmour qui avait
capté toute l'attention médiatique
lorsqu'il a lancé sa campagne est elle
qui a commencé à parler du régalien on
descend dans la cave pour aller chercher
le kärcher de nicolas sarkozy même si on
dit c'est pas forcément une bonne idée
il faudrait trouver d'autres sujets mais
elle a parlé bien entendu des centres de
rétention de la façon dont aussi la
police était un point faible de ce
quinquennat la sécurité des français on
a vu emmanuel macron absents sur ces
sujets là pendant cinq ans il se
réveille à marseille d'abord et puis
maintenant pour voir colmater toutes les
brèches finalement d'une candidature ou
le bilan est calamiteux en matière de
sécurité en matière de police et des
promesses c'est le beauvau c'est les
promesses sur une réélection il parle
comme si cet argent c'était le sien non
c'est le nôtre c'est un plan aussi qui
sera implémentée par peu importe qui
prendra la suite à l'elysée mais on voit
bien qu'il n'y avait pas d'intérêt sur
ces sujets là
et il a fallu du temps pour que mma
qu'on comprenne que c'était un sujet
important pour les français est
d'ailleurs éric soutien s'en est donné à
coeur joie beaucoup plient qu'à droite
un autre et c'est normal si valérie
pécresse veut vraiment existé dans cette
campagne elle doit se démarquer des
moulins mâcon puisqu'un de ses points
faibles c'est d'être trop proche sur
l'europe sur aussi l'économie sur plein
de sujets où on pourrait dire mais
quelle est la différence alors s'il ya
un sujet là où on peut le faire c'est la
fois sur l'immigration sur la sécurité
les thèmes classiques de la droite
sachant bien sûr qu'il ya des outsiders
comme eric zemmour qui peuvent de
déborder à droite eric ciotti a boycotté
la visite officielle du président alors
qui a normalement un accueil républicain
des élus que le président parce que
l'aujourd'hui les républicains doivent
être dans une opposition frontale au
chef de l'état pour exister or ils ne le
sont pas sur le pass vaccinale on le
voit à l'assemblée nationale ils ont
voté alors en ordre dispersé avec
certains qui sont partis comme guillaume
pelletier au sénat on a entendu monsieur
retailleau ce matin dans un entretien
aux échos d'hier que le groupe l'est
républicain votre a majoritairement avec
quelques amendements pour le pass
vaccinale or là c'était une occasion en
or pour embêter empêcher emmanuel macron
et se démarquer et le régalien c'est
évidemment alexis est également un thème
fort de marine le pen la président de la
candidate qui multiplie les déplacements
y at il à un embouteillage à droite sur
sur ce thème sur le thème de sécurité
non il y en a jamais assez ensuite dire
droite et puis c'est 50 nuance de droite
vous avez différentes façons de les
aborder et c'est vrai que c'est assez
étonnant de voir marine le pen qui avait
été un peu fébriles un peu inquiétés
lors du lancement de la campagne d'eric
zemmour finalement retomber sur ses
pattes et se dire de manière assez
olympienne moi je sais ce que c'est
qu'une campagne présidentielle j'ai mes
déplacements de prévu j'ai mon équipe
qui est en place si j'ai des thématiques
j'ai la confiance aussi des français qui
me connaissent eric zemmour a certes
récupéré une signature comme celle de
mieux me pelletier mais ça pèse peu
comparé à la personnalité qui est marine
le pen dans le personnage politique dans
le paysage politique donc on voit bien
que iya finalement de la place pour tout
le monde sur cette thématique d'autant
plus qu'ils menaient macro est en train
d'essayer de jouer de diviser c'est
d'autant plus facile film allemand de
dire sur ce bilan calamiteux nous nous
avons des solutions et autre chose il
faut passer maintenant à autre chose et
pour finir alexis loin de cette année
dans une toute autre problématique car
la gauche qui semble décidément bloqué
dans une bulle par les multiples
candidatures quelle issue possible on se
pose la question oui alors c'est
extrêmement étonnant parce qu'on est à
trois mois d'une élection majeure la
présidentielle et les candidats de
gauche sont enfermés dans une bulle dans
l'impression qu'ils sont pas chez nous
il sera avec nous ils ne parlent que
d'eux qui s'en va qui vient qui fait
cette primaire populaire qui est la
primaire de christiane taubira dirons
nous anne hidalgo qui ne sait pas si
elle y va bon alors il y en a qui
arrêtent et je crois qu'on n'a pas revus
depuis la rentrée c'est arnaud
montebourg mais yannick jadot parlait du
temple solaire en disant que les leaders
de gauche sont en train de se sacrifier
sur l'autel de la désunion et puis jean
luc mélenchon lui a décidé de regarder
ça de our il est déjà un peu limpide en
disant moi ça fait un an que je fais
campagne j'ai des meetings j'ai un
programme venez si vous voulez j'ai
autre chose à faire parce qu'on est à
trois mois d'élections donc c'est
lunaire en fait de voir la gauche qui
clairement abandonné l'idée d'être au
second tour de cette campagne près de la
sortie
s'il ya une issue favorable je pense que
c'est derrière jean-luc mélenchon qui
est haut dans les sondages et qui
d'ailleurs conforte cette avance est
maintenant libre aux leaders de gauche
de le rejoindre ou non mais c'est
ridicule de vouloir faire un vote à
trois mois d'un vote majeur sachant que
la campagne est là la dynamique est là
au sein des troupes insoumise et que le
programme met tout le monde d'accord y
compris les écologistes tout comme le
parti socialiste donc un peu de sérieux
à gauche maintenant il y à une
candidature qui sort du lot il faut
l'admettre c'est celle de jean luc
mélenchon même qu'ils ont du mal à
l'admettre va falloir peut-être sortir
de la bulle en tirer des conséquences
peut-être pour remercier en tout cas
avec six poulains d'avoir été avec nous
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
à nous parlerons du pad vaccinale
justement il est désormais au sénat m
débattu dans l'hémicycle demain le par
pour les j 7 du texte se poursuit donc à
vitesse grand v 5 millions de français
ne sont pas vaccinés justement on
entendra le témoignage de l'un d'entre
eux dans notre rubrique qu'en pensent
les français ce soir et on en débattra
pas
[Musique]
et
je pensais que tout le monde connaissait
déjà kim philby le plus fameux des
espions britanniques après james bond
rappelez-nous pourquoi il s'est tourné
vers le communisme il pensait que la
gauche s'étaient vendus il se disait la
démocratie la démocratie sociale ne fait
pas le travail et il a vu l'avènement
d'hitler en allemagne donc il regardait
l'union soviétique comme un bastion anti
fasciste
l'un des éléments clés selon as
concernant philby
c'est que tout le monde a sous-estimé la
force de son engagement idéologique
l'autre chose qu'il ne faut pas oublier
à son sujet et qu'il avait des capacités
extraordinaires pour la tromperie
c'était un menteur tout à fait brillant
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlocks
l'isolent de la société
new york times
le washington post the guardian
der spiegel hugo
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçu oui mais pas surpris
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
les gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient de l'ignorance aujourd'hui on a
une gauche extrêmement
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
et
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc insu réalité hospitalisé et il
était nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire de cette troisième partie donc
le projet de loi sur le pass vaccinale
examiné au sénat aujourd'hui avant son
retour dans l'hémicycle demain le
gouvernement veut que ce texte entre en
vigueur dès lundi prochain de poids de
compliquer encore un peuple sa vie des
cinq millions de français encore non
vaccinées dans notre rubrique qu'en
pense défense et ce soir nous irons
justement à la rencontre de l'un d'entre
eux qui dénonce une intrusion dans son
intimité alors le pass vaccinale ultime
fracture nette en correction sur le pont
télégramme verte et france
[Musique]
le projet de loi transformant le pass
sanitaires on passe vaccinale est
désormais aussi n'at il est examinée en
ce moment même en commission des lois
avant un retour demain à l'assemblée
nationale c'est dans ce cadre qu olivier
véran été auditionné par les sénateurs
pendant près d'une heure et demie les
détails avec katia technique lors de son
audition le ministre de la santé s'est
appliqué à défendre son bilan les
mesures selon lui non contraignantes
prises par la france il a rappelé que la
majorité parmi les 21 mille hospitalisé
pour que vides étaient des non vaccinés
ou des immunodéprimés ces malades
gravement atteints sur lesquels le
vaccin ne peut pas marcher parlons du
fameux pass vaccinale il serait mis en
place pour les plus de 16 ans les 12 à
15 ans conserverait un passani terre le
ministre a vanté les faits parce
vaccinale qui avait fait battre un
record de primo vaccination la semaine
dernière 230 milles il y aura des
mesures pour lutter contre les fraudes
défaut passe et des contrôles pour que
passer identité correspondent les
sénateurs ont l'air plutôt favorables
aux pass vaccinale mais il ne cote pas
un grand nombre de décisions prises il
estime qu'on pourrait mieux faire dans
certains domaines par exemple pourquoi
les soignants non vaccinés négatif eux
sont suspendus tandis que les vaccinés
infectés mais asymptomatiques vont
travailler
quid des capteurs de co2 pour assainir
des salles par exemple des salles de
classe qui n'ont pas été livrés pourquoi
ces retards dans les annonces de
protocoles scolaire les questions posées
sur l'efficacité du pass sanitaire qui
exige des données précises n'ont pas
vraiment reçu de véritables réponses de
nombreuses questions ont aussi été
posées sur la situation de l'hôpital
alors le ministre a réfuté les chiffres
des fermetures de 5000 lits pour lui
c'est surtout dû au fait qu'on a créé
des chambres simples pour les malades du
co lead en transformant des chambres le
double c'est bien sûr quant à la
question sur la levée des brevets et
bien pour les pays en voie de
développement qui sont demandés par de
grand nombre de militants et de citoyens
il vient selon lui ce n'est pas le
problème il faut donner des doses de
vaccin car selon le ministre ces pays là
non pas les usines adobe pour les
fabriquer le pass vaccinale pour les
jets volant ce n'est ni la halle fanny
l'oméga c'est une mesure supplémentaire
il serait irréaliste de supprimer ce
système de passe les sénateurs n'ont pas
non plus apprécié colis révérend
annoncent qu'ils ne seraient pas là
toute la journée demain pour l'examen du
texte seulement à certains moments
reprise des débats à 14h30 et on ne
rappelle donc 1,5 million de français
qui ne sont pas vaccinés contre le coc
vider le gouvernement qui envisage donc
on l'a entendu une mise en application
du pass vaccinale à partir de lundi
prochain mais qu'en pensent les français
nous sommes allés dans la région
champagne à la rencontre d'un
manifestant qu'on peut pas sanitaires et
le pass vaccinale vous allez voir qu'il
vit la stratégie sanitaire du
gouvernement et tout particulièrement la
vaccination contre le coc bing comme une
intrusion dans son intimité mais pas
seulement dans sa vie de citoyen
également reportage estelle farges
sébastien dufour je suis à reims
aujourd'hui on vous emmène rencontré
sébastien il est membre du mouvement
citoyen anti passe rens
bonjour sébastien devenu merci à
beaucoup ne vouloir bien vouloir
répondre à la question ça me fait
plaisir de vous recevoir ce aujourd'hui
je vous emmène si vous voulez
sébastien on entend beaucoup parler de
propagande anti vague c'est ce que vous
vous définissez comme un anti vaccins
pas du tout en fait ça c'est vraiment ce
qui relève d'une forme d'agitation
médiatique à laquelle on ne peut pas
souscrire et pourtant vous n'êtes avec
signer aujourd'hui alors voilà ça c'est
une question typiquement qui ne qui ne
devrait jamais être posée mais comme
vous me la poser avec beaucoup de
gentillesse je vais vous irez je vais
répondre avec beaucoup de gentillesse
non je ne suis pas vacciné mais en fait
ça ça relève ce qu'on appelle le secret
médical
merci beaucoup
vous me disiez donc dans la voiture que
vous n'étiez pas vaccinés pourquoi est
ce que vous avez fait ce choix
aujourd'hui j'ai compris en tant que
citoyen éclairé que je n'étais pas
exposé aux formes graves aujourd'hui moi
je souscris tout à fait et bien à la
volonté pour certains d'aller se faire
vacciner d'ailleurs je veux bien utilisé
ce terme de façon à rester cohérent par
rapport à la caricature qui parfois est
fait sur vax anti-vaccins c'est pas le
sujet en fait voilà mais cette nuance
est nécessaire et c'est important de le
rappeler en france yann donc le ps
sanitaire bientôt le passé vaccinale qui
va être requis pour accéder à certains
certains établissements pour certains
loisirs comment aujourd'hui est ce que
vous vous organisez votre quotidien je
suis donc comme des millions de
personnes dans une situation de
privation en fait il ya des pans entiers
de ma vie de citoyen qui n'existe plus
je me ré organiser autrement j'essaye de
me d'orienter mes centres d'intérêt sur
des choses qui sont beaucoup plus on va
dire vrai je j'utilise ce mot qui paraît
peut-être un petit peu étonnant c'est à
dire qu'en fait j'ai retiré tout le
superflu et je me recentre sur
l'essentiel et l'essentiel c'est
l'humain au fait donc je ne suis pas
seule en france à avoir ce statut de
citoyens de seconde zone et donc
finalement nous nous retrouvons entre
citoyens de seconde zone je ne me suis
jamais autant senti vivent depuis qu'on
m'a privé de certaines de mes libertés d
employer le terme citoyens de seconde
zone s'en moque et qui est assez fort
quand même oui alors il a même vocation
à devenir encore plus fort dans les
semaines qui viennent puisque
l'expression citoyens de seconde zone
c'était à l'époque du pass sanitaire
avec le pass vaccinale qui vient d'être
acceptée en fait par l'assemblée
nationale même si on sait qu'il va y
avoir des allers retours qui sont
complètement fortuits puisque les choses
sont déjà écrites se passe vaccinale va
beaucoup plus loin donc là en fait nous
serons des hommes et des femmes en
déchéance de citoyenneté
un citoyen de seconde zone peut encore
prétendre avoir certains droits est
aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans une réduction absolue
de ses droits au point d'être d'ailleurs
caricature est décriée et puis mis au
ban de la société dans quel état
d'esprit est ce que vous êtes
aujourd'hui est ce que vous êtes révolté
est ce que c'est de la colère est ce que
vous êtes inquiet aussi je suis inquiet
je suis révolté c'est tout ça en même
temps en fait c'est un espèce de deux
cocktails qui est très difficile à
contrôler parce que il y as en toile de
fond la colère et cette colère on sait
que c'est évidemment quelque chose qui
peut être dangereux je souhaite vraiment
faire cette parenthèse parce que moi je
n'ai pas compris à l'époque ce mouvement
dg les jaunes et maintenant je le
comprends rétroactivement
mais c'est quelque chose qui cette
violence existe déjà depuis longtemps
voilà elle existe aujourd'hui évidemment
elle existait déjà à l'époque rien n'a
été réglé mais ce qui est encore plus
difficile pour ces personnes qui luttait
déjà à l'époque qui sont fait fracasser
c'est que rien n'a été débloqué pour eux
et qu'aujourd'hui on est en train de
mettre sur la table des milliards
et des milliards pour se faire tester
pour s'enfoncer découvrions dans le nez
on ne crée aucune richesse on ne porte
secours à aucune personne on le
redistribue aucune richesse on apporte
le soutien à aucune profession y compris
à celles qui en ont plus besoin comme
les soignants parce que la question
l'hôpital et est sur la table évidemment
donc voilà cette colère elle est encore
plus puissante que celle qu'ils ont vécu
à l'époque et on essaye aussi dans les
cortèges du samedi de canaliser tout
cela pour être audible
on entend donc cette colère silencieuse
nous sommes caricaturer mis au ban de la
société un cocktail très difficile à
contrôler d'où cette question ce soir à
nos deux invités politiques qui vont
donc nous rejoindre en direct dans
quelques instants passe vaccinale
l'ultime fracture c'est l'objet de notre
face à face
[Musique]
et avec nous donc ce soir pour en parler
c'est sillery la députée la république
en marge du val d'oise bonjour madame
relax merci beaucoup d'être avec nous à
vos côtés david xavier weiss
maire-adjoint et l'air de
levallois-perret bonsoir david vives
merci aussi à vous d'être avec nous on
entend un que les positions se
durcissent à travers ce témoignage c'est
important de donner la parole à tout le
monde et on le fait ici sur rt france
une colère donc silencieuse peut être
pire que celle des gilet jaune à nous
disait ce témoin vous avez le sentiment
c'est sillery là que le président la
république en marche d'une certaine
manière à la fracture est le pays avec
ce pas sanitaire puis le pass vaccinale
à présent
c'est pas le
président qui a fracturé la société
c'est malheureusement le virus auxquels
nous sommes confrontés depuis presque
deux ans qui est obligé le gouvernement
à prendre une série de décisions
très importantes
d'abord en instaurant un confinement
ensuite en instaurant un pass
sanitaire est désormais en instaurant un
pass vaccinale toutes ces décisions
elles ont été prises pour
affronter une situation sanitaire hors
norme
que personne n'avait jamais jusqu'à
présent inconnu et
aujourd'hui cette situation
entraîne des divisions au sein de notre
société alors david xavier weiss à
emmanuel macron qui a réagi ce matin la
dérive des antilles vague c'est
inadmissible dit il mais vous dans votre
camp valérie pécresse se dit en
substance que le président l'a l'a un
peu cherché avec justement ses propos
sur les les non vaccinés
vous rejoignez c'est cyril hatt quand
elle dit bah non c'est tout simplement
le virus c'est pas le président de la
république n'est pas le virus si on
compare par exemple et j'ai vu
l'interview du premier ministre belge
qui avait lui-même dit moi je n'aurais
pas utiliser les mêmes book emmanuel
macron ne dit pas j'emmerde les français
quand on est président la république on
le vit pas déjà quand on est responsable
politique mais encore une fois il a
divisé sur tous les sujets mais encore
plus sur la crise sanitaire les français
les uns contre les autres ils à monter
les uns contre les autres et il n'a pas
fait ce ça a été ça d'efforts de
rassemblement et de pédagogie moi enfin
nous à la droite auprès de valérie
pécresse on est pour la vaccination on a
été même des premiers on était force de
propositions y compris en installant des
cornes de vaccination les régions et
notamment la région ile de france a été
la première en la matière déployée à
l'époque les les masques qui ont ensuite
l'étape devait être de vaccinations et
dépistage pour autant on a on n'a jamais
monter les français les uns contre les
autres on a essayé de faire la pédagogie
et je pense que ce qui manque
aujourd'hui notamment chez certains les
élus la république en marche mais pas
tous dans le même panier mais on a bien
vu que il ya aujourd'hui des députés qui
sont la cible et je condamne de de
violence et d' attaque mais ça prouve
bien que c'est la société qui a été mise
sous tension et ce n'est pas le virus
était mis sous tension c'est là dessus
ça a été arrêté sur le virus mais avant
l'avant le corps d'un virus était sur
les gilet jaune et on a bien vu cette
france qui était fracturée cette france
qui a été aussi stigmatisé par à
l'époque par edouard philippe et alors
ensuite par emmanuel macron on voit bien
que depuis cinq ans on a une chance ou
tension parce qu'on a un exécutif qui
est assez méprisant on ne dit pas encore
une fois j'en ai à les français quand on
n'est pas d'accord on essaye d'avoir un
débat constructif d'essayer de
rassembler non ne stigmatise pas ou ne
montre pas du doigt ceux qui ont pour
diverses raisons peur du vaccin et puis
il ya des gens qui ont une incapacité à
pouvoir être vacciné il ya des gens qui
ont des comptes dingue comptabilité
médical alors certes c'est très peu de
monde c'est peut-être un pour cent de la
population il ya des gens qui ont parlé
des problèmes cardiaques qui ne peuvent
pas être vaccinés ni par pfizer ni
pâmoison justement vous y faisiez
référence à quelques instants à cesser
c'est lui qui sont agressés on va vous
montrer
la dernière agression en date le député
de saint pierre et miquelon qui a été
pris pour cible par des antilles vaz
avec des jets de projectiles de l'encens
son domicile regarder
cécile année là quand on arrive à ce
niveau de violence on se dit quoi en
tant qu'élu en condamnant bloc où on
essaie justement de comprendre peut-être
cette colère et le font de cette colère
des gens condamnons blocs d'autant plus
que stéphane guéro est non seulement un
collègue mais devenu un ami depuis
quatre ans puisque je travaille à ses
côtés au sein de la délégation outre mer
donc oui ces images m'ont profondément
choquée je les appelais dès hier soir
pour justement prendre de ses nouvelles
et savoir comment humainement il vivait
la chose mais là où en effet il avait
agi en essayant justement d'écouter
cette colère en voulant dialoguer avec
donc à une manifestation anti passe et
non pas anti vague c'est je pense que
tout le monde a raison aujourd'hui de
faire la dire la différence tous les
anti-pacs ce ne sont pas des anti lax et
ça a dégénéré il a reçu des projectiles
à la figure et ça c'est tout c'est tout
à fait scandaleux
tout à l'heure le la personne que vous
interviewez avait un discours très posé
on voit bien que il y a les moyens de
discuter le l'adjoint au maire de
levallois perret le disait aussi dans
nos circonscriptions nous discutons avec
les élus locaux justement pour depuis le
début mettre en place le mieux pour se
faire soigner pour se faire dépister
pour faire en sorte que la vie des
français soit sur la meilleure possible
moi je pense au compte que c'est ont
travaillé ensemble qu'on pourra
affronter cette épreuve est
pas en divisant et c'est vrai que je
suis pas une fan des petites phrases qui
blessent les gens je préfère avoir des
débats qu'ils soient apaisées et qu'on
puisse essayer de discuter trouver des
solutions communes mais aujourd'hui la
situation est telle que à mon sens on ne
peut pas aller à l'encontre basso
vaccinale pour l'ensemble de la
population alors la question le pass
vaccinale l'ultime fracturé un qu'en
pensent les français on a eu quelques
réactions sur notre compte télégramme
l'ultime fracture a été lorsque
justement on en parlait le président
insulté et déclaré non citoyens les
non-vaccinés non vaccinés qui
n'enfreignent aucune loin vu qu'il n'ya
pas d'obligation david-xavier weiss si
vous étiez vous à la tête de ce pays
comment vous vous
débrouillez pour convaincre puisque
c'est votre position vous êtes en faveur
du vaccin par quel bout prendre ce
problème seulement vont de deux choses
l'une soit le le premier le président de
la république avait eu le courage de
dire à écouter on fait la vaccination
obligatoire et dans ces cas là n'ont
nourri on y serez tout se passait et les
récalcitrants pouvait être poursuivi que
j'ai déjà vu une tribune d'ailleurs d'un
parisien à qui proposer de poursuivre
ceux qui refusaient d'être vacciné pour
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui mais
ça n'a pas été le choix donc un moment
donné si on impose par par la loi il
faut faire de la pédagogie et on ne peut
marquer encore une fois des français les
uns contre les autres il fallait faire
ça dans vont tout simplement rendre
obligatoire il aurait fallu faire il
aurait fallu faire déjà bien en amont
avoir une politique vaccinale beaucoup
plus agressive on va dire ça comme ça
mais dès le début on a vu que à l'époque
où ils verront tâtonner rappelez-vous du
la dune et ma rage très lent il ya un an
sur la sur la vaccination on n'a pas
pris la mesure de ce combat contre la
montre était celle de de ce combat
contre le virus c'était un combat contre
la montre on l'a pris un peu à chaque
fois avec un peu de un peu de décalage
par rapport à d'autres pays et je pense
notamment à israël qui était un peu plus
en avance que nous en la matière et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve finalement à
une échéance et on va pas se mentir et
effectivement l'élection présidentielle
est une échéance qui est dans la tête de
tout le monde et qui perturbe un peu 7,7
cette course à la vaccination est donc
aujourd'hui on a deux des pâquis
s'oppose la vaccination
faut-il la rendent obligatoire à mon
sens oui moi je suis je suis un pro
vaccin je pense qu'il faut faire
confiance en la rendant la médecine et
puis de toute façon on est bien vu que
ça que sa protégée en tout cas ce que
ceux qui de ceux qui le passé par par la
vaccination
même si ce n'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga
il ya aussi d'autres traitements tu ne
sois pas forcément aujourd'hui ni assez
bien exploité unis même favorisée par la
recherche je pense que les traitements
sont aussi une autre arme que le vaccin
qui n'ont pas forcément été un des choix
non plus du gouvernement et c'est bien
dommage qu'on n'ait pas miser sur tous
les chevaux en même temps alors on va
regarder justement cette tribune à
laquelle vous faisiez allusion david
xavier valls 'la tribune' ce matin dans
le parisien la loi doit sanctionner ceux
qui refusent le vaccin
voilà loin qui doit sanctionner ceux qui
refusent le vaccin et transmettent le
virus à ses l'appel d'un d'un médecin et
d'un avocat david smadja benjamin fall
où est ce qu'on va trop loin cécile
relax c'est l'illustration clairement de
cette tribune il faut aller jusqu à
punir parce qu'on transmet le virus et
on met en danger la vie d'autrui non
clairement de luz est pas la position
pas pris le président de la république
ce gouvernement et cette majorité depuis
le début nous avons pris la décision
politique de responsabiliser les gens de
faire confiance à nos concitoyens
c'est pour ça que nous n'avons pas rendu
obligatoire la vaccination et c'est
aussi pour ça qu'aujourd'hui pour tenir
cette ligne politique
on ne veut pas le rendre obligatoire
parce que justement on ne veut pas
qu'ils puissent derrière il y avoir des
sanctions
la vie est déjà assez difficile en ce
moment pour pour tout le monde quelles
que soient les professions mais on doit
continuer à protéger nos concitoyens et
aujourd'hui on doit aussi surtout penser
à nos soignants ça va faire deux ans qui
sont sur le front ça fait deux ans
qu'il lutte contre ce virus
et c'est vrai que d'avoir pendant 18
mois moi je discutais encore j'ai encore
eu des témoignages de soignants dans mon
département c'est très difficile pour
eux de supporter de voir les gens mourir
alors qu'ils sont soignants et qu'ils
sont anormalement pour eux faire en
sorte qu'ils ne décèdent pas et
aujourd'hui on a une désaffection des
services de réanimation parce que les
personnels ne veulent plus être en
service de réanimation parce qu'il ne le
supporte plus donc il ya aussi ça dans
le pass vaccinale une responsabilité
parce qu'on a des hôpitaux où il y as
suffisamment normalement de personnes
mais aujourd'hui par la maladie parce
qu'il faut s'occuper des enfants parce
qu'il ya des arrêts de travail et parce
qu'on a aussi des conditions de travail
excessivement dure depuis deux ans c'est
aussi ça le pass vaccinale c'est aussi
protéger
et faire en sorte que nos soignants
puissent continuer leur métier pas dans
les meilleures conditions parce que
c'est aujourd'hui impossible mais en
tout cas dans des consignes on dans des
conditions des mots clés en tout cas ce
texte on le disait arrivée au sénat
avant de retourner à l'assemblée
nationale le tout évidemment dans une
ambiance électrique regarder ces
quelques tweets d'abord celui du
sénateur ps de paris bernard jomier qui
défendent est la vaccination obligatoire
il ya encore quelques semaines
nous débutons au sénat l'examen de la
loi sur le pass vaccinale avec
l'audition d'olivier vers ans rappelons
que cette loi n'aura aucun impact sur la
vague en cours aucun l'urgence est de
réduire la circulation du virus et sur
ce point le dispositif proposé ne
changera rien j'ai déposé un amendement
en commission des lois du sénat qui
propose non seulement de renoncer au
pass vaccinale mais de supprimer
définitivement le pass sanitaires david
xavier weiss ont sans embarras à droite
un parce que voilà on est en substance
ont globalement pour la vaccination mais
la manière d'y parvenir mais n'est pas
toujours évidente
dans votre parti non c'est pas ça c'est
qu'il ya effectivement une pluralité de
points de vue effectivement l'assemblée
nationale il y avait on va dire un blog
division 3 pour contrer une forme d'
abstention au scénar c'est un peu plus
uniforme et en la matière il ya quand
même un consensus on sait très bien moi
j'ai reçu d'ailleurs la semaine dernière
bernard jomier à levallois pour pour
visiter une école l'école buffon on voit
bien que beaucoup d'élus les élus locaux
font beaucoup d'efforts pour limiter la
propagation du virus mais qu'on dit bien
les choses aux français qu'on soit on
soit honnête en la matière c'est pas
pour limiter cette vague c'est le pass
vaccinale n'aura aucun impact sur 7 sur
la vague en cours tu as un wagon micro
et encore moins sur celle qui est en
train d'arriver de chypre il faut voilà
il faut pas qu'on a qu'on arrive à ce
que deux débats celui là déjà
présidentielle et celui du la lutte
contre ce virus s'entrechoquent
aujourd'hui on attendait un peu la mine
un peu en train d'instrumentaliser le
débat et de la crise sanitaire
à cause des échéances des échéances
présidentielles qui sont dans deux mois
on voit bien on et reese la peur des
français à travers ce à travers ce débat
et c'est un peu dommage qu'on n'ait pas
un débat plus apaisé on a des
parlementaires et vous en êtes un
exemple madame début des parlementaires
qui sont responsables dans leurs
circonscriptions qui ont un discours
posé on l'a pas toujours ressenti au
niveau de l'exécutif alors justement
mais leurs soixante dix huit ans c'est
un message qui nous est parvenu aussi
sur télégramme semble partager votre
opinion en veut pas de ça ni talent ce
sont des emmerdes maximale pour emmanuel
macron tarte à la crème et tous ses
déplacements de campagne justement la
campagne 1 et cette stratégie sanitaire
cécile relax est une erreur qui qu'il a
fait quand même emmanuel macron parce
que comme le dit david xavier weiss on
mélange un petit peu cette politique
sanitaire et la campagne présidentielle
qui arrive à grands pas enfin il ya déjà
d'ailleurs entamé largement on
connaissait tous notre président on sait
très bien que tous les mots sont pesées
donc lui de son point de vue politique
il ne commet pas d'erreurs maintenant
moi de mon point de vue de parlementaire
je peux vous avouer que ce fameux mardi
soir où j'étais dans l'hémicycle où on
en a on savait qu'on allait avoir une
deuxième nuit de débat
d'un point de vue personnel en tant que
parlementaire c'est vrai que j'ai trouvé
ces propos qui n'était pas qu'ils
n'étaient pas les bienvenus parce que
sont volontaires s'étaient pas fortuit
ah bah non et de toute manière le
président ne l'a encore confirmé il a il
a affirmé ces propos ce ne sont pas des
propos fortuit le président a appris une
posture politique
pour dire qu arrive à un moment ça
suffisait qu'il fallait absolument que
tous les français et je le répète
adultes majeurs réagissent face à
l'épidémie que nous essayons contenir
depuis 18 mois en limitant les
problématiques fine économique en
limitant la la perturbation des écoles
en limitant justement la perturbation
des hôpitaux donc tout ça ça pèse sur le
quotidien de tous les français donc il
ya eu un gros effort de fait depuis 18
mois donc le président a utilisé un
vocabulaire très non pas injurieux mais
très populaire
la deuxième chose pour moi il n'y a pas
eu et pour beaucoup d'entre nous il n'y
a pas eu d'insultés par rapport aux
citoyens il faut pas prendre
le mot citoyen au sens non il n'y a pas
de division n'y a pas des citoyens de
première catégorie de cette seconde
catégorie celle n'y en a jamais eu et
j'espère qu'il n'y en aura jamais
c'était plutôt pour au sens du civisme
voilà donc c'était aussi peut-être un
appel un
violon peut-être alors à la citoyenneté
david xavier weiss une erreur de
campagne au contraire c'est sur ce
registre là finalement que l'on peut
capitaliser
je pense que c'est pleinement assumé il
ne fait pas d'erreur de 2 séparent
quelqu'un qui fait des erreurs de
langage des abus le langage sepa sepa
donald trump quand ils s'expriment et
notamment encore plus quand c'est dans
un média comme comme le parisien médias
écrits il sait très bien que chaque
phrase chaque mot est pesé va être
repris et il l'a fait à dessein a laissé
encore plus graves ont fait quelque part
ce serait ce serait vous souvenez quand
nicolas sarkozy avait lui a répondu
casse-toi pauv' con dans a laissé tous
des gorges chaudes bon là c'était que
c'était quelqu'un qui agressait
président de la république il lui a
répondu ça a laissé des choux gras
pendant pendant plusieurs semaines là
c'est un une interview bien pesé avec
des mots choisis avec et finalement il a
quand même créé des citoyens
contrairement à ce qui a été dit des
citoyens de seconde zone ils osent ils
expriment très clairement il veut mettre
au ban de la société ceux qui sont les
plus récalcitrants dans ces
récalcitrants il ya encore une fois il
ya des gens qui ont des appréhensions
n'a peut-être pas fait assez pédagogique
tous ensemble collectivement je pense
que encore une fois je ne cherche pas à
diviser ni à l'air m denis allaire on
est tous dans la même barque on est tous
face à ce virus mais il ya aussi des
gens qui ont peur de ceux de ce vaccin
et d'autres qui ont l'âme des
contre-indications par rapport à ce
vaccin est pour vous n'y a aucune
réponse qui est apportée
le pad vaccinale pour ceux qui ne
peuvent pas se faire vacciner notamment
pour des raisons cardiaque ils ne nous
ont pas de padirac finale donc c'est un
peu compliqué
parce que c'est un amendement que j'ai
porté à l'assemblée et
une réponse on a enfin obtenu justement
une réponse par rapport à cela c'est à
dire que
pour le pass annie terre donc il y avait
une attestation particulière d'un
médecin et le ministre s'est engagé à ce
que justement il puisse y avoir un qr
code parce que là monsieur vous avez
tout à fait raison c'est qu'il y avait
une partie de nos concitoyens qui ne
pouvaient pas satisfaire à l'obligation
vaccinale pour différentes raisons
médicales et normalement en tout cas
c'est pour ça que j'ai retiré mon
amendement parce que j'ai obtenu de la
part du ministre c'était mercredi soir
aux alentours de 19 heures si vous
voulez regarder la vidéo
que justement cette situation allait
être à allait être amélioré en tout cas
pour ces catégories comme vous l'avez
dit très peu nombreuses mais pour eux
c'est très important merci en tout cas
tous les deux david xavier weiss et
s'ils risquent d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt français c'est la fin de
cette émission se retrouvent demain à 20
heures pour un nouveau numéro excellente
soirée à tous et l'actualité qui
continue ce faire et france
[Musique]
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlocks
l'isolent de la société
le new york times le washington post the
guardian
der spiegel go
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçu oui mais pas surpris
[Musique]
olivier maintenant détenu depuis huit
mois quelles sont les nouvelles les
nouvelles y en a très peu
malheureusement elles sont coupés de
tout il n'est pas dans un hôtel
capturé avec un téléphone et il peut me
donner des nouvelles non à votre avis
quelles sont ses conditions de détention
aujourd'hui c'est sûr elles sont très
difficiles parce que les anciens otages
ont qu une
nous le racontait qu'il a des conditions
de vie qui sont très rudimentaires et
très dur j'espère vraiment de tout mon
coeur qui qui ressent notre énergie moi
j'essaye de faire de mon mieux bien sûr
tout simplement pour qu'ils m'entendent
parce que c'est ça mon travail c'est la
france et le mali où la france ou le
mali qui vont libérer olivier g pas ce
pouvoir de libérer mais par contre j'ai
le devoir de mobilisation je ne
l'abandonnerai part je ne laisserai pas
bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
fois n'est pas coutume je vais féliciter
monsieur macron pour son éclair de
lucidité oui vous nous emmerdez depuis
cinq ans
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ces
caches une émission consacrée cette
semaine aux gros titres de l'actualité
économique au menu donc le variant
omicron et bercy qui renforce ses aides
pour venir en aide aux entreprises on
parlera de cette vague de fusions
acquisitions qui a déferlé en france en
2021 et puis au sommaire un anniversaire
celui de l'euro et qui fête ses 20 ans
on va évoquer à tout cela avec vous
olivier a bien évidemment bonjour
olivier bonjour et puis face à vous
nathalie jenson économistes et
enseignante chercheuse à l'école de
management neoma business school bonjour
natalie bougeard sur ce plateau merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation on va
commencer à part ce qui occupe beaucoup
à l'actualité c'est le variant omicron
fin décembre jean castex a annoncé de
nouvelles mesures restrictives pour
tenter d'endiguer cette vague ainsi les
aides pour les entreprises affectés par
les restrictions sanitaires vont être
renforcé et élargi c'est le cas
notamment dans le secteur du tourisme
avec le grand retour du chômage partiel
sans reste à charge les bases du
déclenchement de ce dispositif sont
élargies et toutes les entreprises qui
auront perdu 65 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires contre 80 % jusqu'à présent
pourront en bénéficier
le dispositif de prise en charge des
coûts fixes réservé jusqu'à présent un
nombre limité d'entreprises sera quant à
lui élargie à l'ensemble des entreprises
du tourisme le seuil d'accès à ce
dispositif est lui aussi abaissé à 50 %
de perte de chiffre d'affaires contre 60
5% auparavant olivier est ce que cela
signifie concrètement que c'est le
retour à une économie sous perfusion
abete totalement ici il ya quelques il
ya quelques mois quand bruno le maire
avait annoncé la fin ou sonner du quoi
qu'il en coûte et bien un jld avait ri
jaune mais j'avais pris en disant que
évidemment le quoi qu'il en coûte ne
s'arrêtait pas est bien la preuve en est
c'est que non seulement il ne s'arrête
pas mais c'est encore j'irai pire
qu'avant et
aujourd'hui on est obligé à cause des
mesures qu'ils prennent c'est pas le
covin n'y est pour rien là dedans le
pauvre petit virus ne bloque pas
l'économie c'est bien eux il a bloqué
qui
structurent il ya de nouvelles mesures
restrictives d'accord mais c'est
justement à cause de ces nouvelles
mesures restrictives que vous avez
besoin de soutenir l'économie et de
larmes est sous perfusion donc vous la
mettez sous perfusion on sait que de
toute façon on l'a dit dit fois alors
visiblement c'est pas encore rentré dans
la tête des énarques mais quand l'état
paye c'est qu'il est assez vous c'est
nous donc on va le payer d'une manière
ou d'une autre dans les impôts dans ce
que vous voulez mais ça n'est que un
déplacement finalement d'argent pour
soutenir une économie qui est moribonde
depuis longtemps mais ça fait plaisir à
monsieur le maire de pouvoir annoncer
encore une fois que la croissance est
extraordinaire en france la croissance
c'est surtout la croissance de la dette
qui est extraordinaire en france et est
là la croissance de la dépense publique
mais la dépense publique il ya quelqu'un
qui la règle et je vous dis c'est nous
s'est
amusé alors oui de toute façon en partie
il est vrai que là on ne fait
qu'accumuler des des plans dead et comme
vous l'avez justement souligné parce
qu'effectivement comme le gouvernement
décide d'arrêter certains secteurs en
tout cas de limiter leurs activités là
pour le coup il crée un effet unesco et
le nectar des négatives liées aux
qu'ovide et dans ce cas il n'y a pas
vraiment d'autre choix puisque ils
l'imposent au secteur privé de les
compenser là on peut pas dire
qu'effectivement pourtant j'ai une
position plutôt assez libérale en
général mais là lorsqu'une dans ce cas
c'est une restriction d'activité
imposées par l'état je vois pas comment
effectivement l'état pourrait ne pas en
fait compensé pour cette baisse
d'activité
ce qui est regrettable
ici c'est que en effet on va prendre des
heavy d'amendé plan de soutien enfin on
va donner des accords d'aidé au soutien
des entreprises qui sont directement
touchés mais en fait il ya plein
d'activités qui vont être indirectement
touchés et qui à nouveau ça va donner
lieu à bas pourquoi pas moi et pourquoi
pas pourquoi les autres parce que
objectivement ils ont une activité
restreinte mais néanmoins cela n'empêche
pas les effets collatéraux négatifs
on peut penser à la restauration qui par
l'effet du télétravail va se retrouver à
nouveau effectivement baisse d'activité
et j'imagine qu'ils seront aussi
éligibles donc on rentre à nouveau dans
un cercle en effet